今日はダンマパダの偈一つを選んでみる回でございまして
七十九番目になっている句なんですね
ダンマピーティ・スカンセーティ・ヴィッパサンネーナ・チェータサー・アリアッパウェーディテ・ダンメー・サダーラマティ・パンディトー
意味を申し上げます ダンマピーティ・スカンセーティというのは
ダンマっていうのはお釈迦様に説かれた真理のことで
法なんですね お釈迦様に説かれた真理に対して喜びを感じるならば
その人がということで
ダンマピーティというのは人のことなんですね
ブッダに説かれた教えに対してすごく喜びを感じる人
スカンセーティというのは大変幸福で生活するんだよと
理由は次にいますね ヴィッパサンネーナ・チェータサー
チェータサーというのは気持ちのこと
意志ですね 心のことですね
その心がとても清らかになっているのです
とても美しい清らかに心になっているんだからこそ
その人は何の悩みも苦しみもなく
ものすごい気持ちよく穏やかに生きているんだと
それから三番目のセクションと二行目ですね
そちらで我々に対するアドバイス入ですね
ですから ですからというところはちょっと入れておかないと
ですからアリアッパウェーディテ・ダンメー
ですからアリアッパウェーディタっていうのは
聖者に発見された真理
悟りに達した いわゆるブッダに発見された真理
ブッダが発見した真理に対してサダーラマティ・パンディトー
理性のある人は常に喜びを感じるんだと
だからそちらで感じると言ってますけど
本当はあなた方もそういう風にした方がいいんじゃないのかという提案ですね
二行目 三行目 三行目 四行目は
だから偈というのは四行に切って見るんですから
ただの詩というよりも
ものすごい論理構成がありまして
その論理構成の中で詩を作らなくちゃいけないんですね
その場合は この詩を作るときのこの決まりというのは完璧に守られてあるのはブッダのブッダの言葉だけなんです
こういう詩の作り方とかは
インド文化でサンスクリット文化でね
ブッダより前からも決めてあったんです
こういう風に こういう風に作るものだよと
決まりはありましたけど
誰にでもそんな能力ないんですね
しっかりと四行目で言いたいことは全部言い尽くすということの能力はないんです
ですから 4つに分けてみると
一番目では表現したい事実を発表する
ダンマピーティスカンセーティと
ブッダに説かれた教えに対して喜びを感じる人が幸福に生活する
次に出てくるのは それはなんでまたどういうわけかという理由を知りたくなるんですね
ですから 2番目に理由を言うのです
ヴィッパサンレーナチェータサ
心がすごく清浄に 清らかになる
清らかになった心で生活しているだからでしょう
それで理由をはっきり言っているのです
で 次の 2つで ですから
こういうことになりますよという結論を出すんですね
どういうことになるかというと
理性のある人は常に聖者に発見された真理に喜びを感じるんだよと
ですから 理性のある人々はこうしますよというところは
本当は読む人に対するアドバイスなんですね
だからはっきり言ってないんだから
あなた方もそうやりなさいと
無視する自由はいくらでもあります
そんなのはやりませんよと
やりたくないんだよと
お釈迦様言うのは 理性があるならば
聖者に説かれた真理に喜びを感じるんだよと
だから ずいぶん軽々とブッダの言葉を聞く人々は否定しますけど
ブッダの教えはね 否定すると同時に
自分で自分の頭におぶすかぶるようなことにもなります
なぜならば それは見事に言ってます
理性あるならばということを言ってますからね
あまり私には気に入らないと言ったら
ひとかけらも理性のない原始人だということは自分で表現することになるのです
だからもうすごいあの
2行目かもしれませんだけど
言い方はもうこれほど完璧には言えません
だからブッダの話には興味がないんだとかね
そんな変なことは私はやりたくないとかね
我々は現代人はもっとしっかりしたもの好きだよとか
何と言っても もう自分で自分を非難することになるのです
なぜならば お釈迦様ははっきり言うのです
理性のある人はこの教えに喜びを感じます
感じますよと 賢者は喜びを感じますよと
あんた嫌いですか？はい
どうぞと 構いませんよと
先生 それには何としてでもとにかく仏教を理解してください
守ってくださいということは言いません
そういうのはすごい厳しい態度かもしれませんだけど
やっぱりあの 人間って
とても情けない 全然成長しない
発展しない生き物で それほど立派じゃないんですよ
だから未だに女性差別がキリがないし
昨日も NHK の古い番組でほんのちょっとだけ見て消しちゃったんですけど
部落人々の差別されて長い間
歴史的にね 酷い目に合わせてきたという
同じ人間でね 人間を差別するということはね
すごいもう動物はやらないんですよ
動物はやらない 同じ仲間は仲間なんです
仲間の中でそれぞれ決まりがありまして
単独行動する動物もいるし
群れで行動する動物もいるし
それぞれが決まりがありまして
ちゃんとそれを守って生活しているんです
戦うことになったら戦うのは明らかにあの必要な戦いであって
子孫を残す場合は一番環境に適応できる強いものを作らなくちゃいけないんです
だからそれも人間より優れているんです
誰でも子供を作るんじゃないんだよと
子供を作るんだったら
まあやっぱり体力ぐらいはなければダメやと
そこはまた自然法則に従って
動物の世界でオスたちは戦いますけど
誰も殺しはしません そこで勝負が決めたら
潔く負けた人は下がるし
勝った人は交尾して子孫を作ることになるんです
それ以外は仲間の間で差別するということはね
ないんです だから人間というのはすごく偉いと自分たちで思うんだから
なおさらかっこ悪いんです
ものすごい自分たちがすごく立派で
高等動物であれやこれやとかね
思ってはいるんですけど
ろくに子育てさえできないんです
夫婦仲良くすることができないんです
体にいい食べ物は何か
悪いもの何かそれわからないんです
何を見てももう情けないんですけど
その上 我が輩は世界生命第一やというこの態度
それから宗教の本なんか読んでみてください
人間が特別やと アメリカの映画なんか見ると
もうものすごくもう殺しの映画ばっかりですけど
人間以外はいくら殺してもいいというね
このエイリアンの映画とか見ると
もうエイリアンは人間の格好をしていても平気で殺すと
あれは人間じゃないんだということで
人間だけすごく偉いと
あれって文化の影響ですからね
映画を作る人々は必ずもう愚か者に見てほしいというね
でないとものすごい大金儲かりませんということで
何もメッセージもない最低の映画を作ったり
本を書いたり出したりはしています
だから狙いはね まあボックスオフィス狙ってますからね
無茶お金使いますからね
映画作る場合 だからそこは倍
倍にして返ってこないと
そういうことだから 一番人が無知であった方がよろしい
だからそういう風に作ったりしても
だからそういう人を出したのは
やっぱり人間だけ偉いというこの態度もね
なおさらかっこ悪いんですよ
で 仏教を破壊した人々は我々は大丈夫やと言ったことと同じなんです
自分が破壊してたのに
破壊してない人は清浄やと
それで私たちに強引にあんた方清浄仏教でしょうと
誰が知るもんか そんなのは
言ってるのはあなたですか？と
ある意味ではあなたが言ったらね
それあなた言うんだから正しいと思ってるんですか？と
まずはあなたは全て知ってるんだと証拠を出しなさいよ
ある人はすごい そういうあの方丈経こそ素晴らしくて
大乗仏教よりも優れている
なんだらかんだら何か情がありましてね
そんなに最高なことはあるのに
なんであなた方は一番レベルの低い沙門将をやっているんでしょうかと
本人が沙門将菩薩上独覚上とかもうランクつけてるんですね
華厳とかね その上自分の教えはもっと上とかね
言ってることはもう信憑感なくてくだらないというとね
まあ仏教が学んでないんだからね
ありがたいことですけど
私はこの人とはね 学問的には喋ることはできないんだと
もうむちゃくちゃもういろんなもう本も書いてありましたしね
自分こそ世界知識人だと言っておいても
どれほどアホかということを示すことっていうのは
私にとってはいたって簡単だよと
と心で思って なんのことなく
その分析は最初にやったのは誰ですかと
天台智厳でしょうと だから天台智厳が何か言ったらそれが事実で
他の人の言うことは全て間違ってるんだよという立場ですかと
他人類の中で誰にも事実を言えない
天台智厳という狂ってる人にしか言えないんですかと
それに返事出さないで
偉そうな知識人ですけど
質問したら答えるのは普通エリートのやり方なんですけど
そこで興奮してキャーキャーキャーキャーと言ってあれやこれやとかね
私にまで逆にもう怒鳴ってやろうと思ったりするんですね
私はそれは全然受けることなく
ニコニコと笑って あのね
先生 私が勝手に私が世界一頭がいい人やと言ったら
確実にそれで私は世界一頭の人になるんですか？と
私が誰かに向かってあなたは世界一バカやと言ったら
その人は確実に世界一バカですか？と
あんた言ってるのはそういう理屈だよと
だから大乗仏教の連中には我は大乗仏教と勝手に言うことできますけど
我々から見ればね 仏教じゃないんだと
それで それだけでその組織が壊れたんです
うかつに当たってはいけません
で 組織はそれで終わり
私たちの目の前で惨めになっちゃったんだから
一つの質問で 大量に書いたものをやらせる
それでまあゴミになって
まあしょうがないんですけど
まあ私もブッダを侮辱したんだからね
知ったことじゃないんだと
ブッダを侮辱しなかったならば助けてあげましたけどね
まあそういうことで この
まあそれは一つの例だけのことで
あまり役に立たない例でよかったんですね
で 我々偉いというのはね
始めいいところなんですよ
だから私はこれをもっと大きい論理に持っていきたいんですけど
人類というものがものすごく変なんです
動物と比較したとしても
動物はもう本当にひっぱり合ってるのに
人間っていうのはもうなんとかなんとかもうなんとか頑張ってるだけなんですね
だから人間にこの考えるというね
いわゆる現実化離れしてね
考える能力というものがあるんだから
自分たちが偉いと思ってますけど
それって分析してみたら通ったことはないし
人間すごい創造力あると思ってますけど
あれってまた激な勘違いで
この考えるものっていうのはもうどうったことなく日常の経験をもう無作為に無作為
無作為というんですか
無作為に組み立てるだけ
それ自体屁理屈なんですけど
動物はそんな馬鹿なことはしないんです
それで無作為に経験したものを組み合わせると
時々そういうものを現実化することもできます
それは時々なんで 例えば鳥たちは空を飛べるということはね
ちゃんと目で見えている経験なんですね
人間は飛べないということはちゃんと経験ですね
そこでそれをつなげるんですよ
人間が空を飛ぶと で そこがもう神話に行ったり
いろんなことに言ったり
空飛ぶ絨毯作ったり いろいろ出てあげれますけど
まぁ一部の人々はなんか飛べる方法はないのかと考えて飛行機を開発するんです
それで人間が偉いということになるのかと
で考えるものは何でもよろしいけど
なんで空飛ぶ絨毯を作らないんですかね
それだったら だからこの考えるものを何でも実現することはできませんだけど
僅かなことだけ で 組み立てることはできるようになっていて
それはあくまでも猿ですから
猿 猿と違うところは道具使うんですね
だから道具を使ったことは
自分が存在としてすごく弱かったんですね
弱かったんだから もうなんとかなんとか道具使う
使う始めて 最初は骨を食わして
もう動物が獲物にとって食べて捨てていったところで
もう自分たちには狩り物できない
狩りできないし だから動物捨てた骨を砕いて
中にある骨髄とか食べたりしていたっていう話を聞いたんですけどね
それだったら骨を砕くために石一つ取らなくちゃいけないんですね
まぁそれでは破れませんしね
そういうところからどんどんまぁ道具使う
作る能力 使う能力が開発されていって
いまだに道具作る能力以外何も持っていないんです
まだこの前テレビでなんか一般人にはいろいろアイデアを出してくださいという組織があるみたいですね
そちらにアイデアを出したら
向こうはもういろいろプロの人々だから
ちゃんと工場でそういうアイデア OK になったら
物 品物を作るんだと で作ったところで
アイデアを出した人にもそれなりのいくらか報酬が入るんだということで
一般人にはアイデアがありますけど
作る能力はないんだということ
技術はないでしょうということで
組織できちゃって まぁ悪いことではないんですけど
まぁそれで生き延びることができるしね
だから私が言いたいのは
そういうことそれが悪いという意味じゃなくて
皆様にアイデアあったら出しちゃえば
もしかすると良かったら結構儲かりますよ
出してください しかし
あくまでも道具作りなんですね
いまだに我々は猿の時代で道具作り始めたんですけど
いまだに道具ばっかり作ってるだけなんです
まぁ そんなもんで まぁ頭が悪いんだから
我こそすごく偉いという風に思っていてね
まぁ なかなか大変ですよ
そういうことで このお釈迦様が語りかけているのは
まぁもうちょっと理性に基づいて
物事を自分で考える能力があることがとてもありがたいことであると
歴史が長くなればなるほど
人間っていうのは過去の知識そのまんま運ぶんでしょ
運んでそれが自分だと勘違いするし
我々やっていることは一人一人調べてみると
なんでそんなことやってるのかとか
もう自分よりも前に誰かがやったんだからなんです
どんなことでもそうなっているんです
だから私たちは何か自分で考えてやっているのかと
年数経つたびに 結局はそのそれが低くなるんじゃないかなと思いますよ
初期時代ではね 原始時代で
人々はやっぱりそれなりに何か新しいものを考えたりしたでしょうと
それが次の世代に伝わったら
その分は考えなくても済みますね
そこで今になってくると
もう長い時間歴史だから
大量なこと 過去の人間が考えておいたんです
結局我々はそればっかり運んでいるだけであって
もう次の世代に対する新しいということはほとんどない
例として この 服のデザイン系の世界を見てみるとよくわかります
毎年何回もやっているでしょう
もう新しい今年の作品
春の作品 冬の夏 あれやこれやとか
どうったことないんです
ただ 恥ずかしくて着て 1本も歩けないぐらいの服だけで
で テレビで見るんですけど
そんなもの実際着ているの人は一人も見たことないんです
だから何か作品を作って発表するだけで
それは売らないんですよ
その代わりにその素材を作ったりして
微妙にそのデザインの微妙な何か取ったりして売りに出すんです
あれ 恥ずかしくて着たら部屋から出たらあかんという
もしかすると法律でも裁かれるかもしれませんと
大変な で まあただ単にその現場であ
楽しい かっこいい 美しいというだけで終わっちゃうんです
それどれぐらいお金かかるのかと
舞台の上ではね まあどんな服装でもどうったことないんだからね
法律違反にはなりませんし
で それでよくそういうおしゃれの世界で見えることはリピートされるんですね
新しいものと言ったっても
本当は 20年前やっても
着たものには少々の改良を入れただけという
だからこの結構苦労しているとは思いますよ
新しい作品を作るということはね
だって考える余地がないんだからね
もうこの体でしょうに
それに もう体にはめることできない服装だったっても意味がないでしょうに
それだったら昔の人はしっかりと考えちゃったんだからね
これなら便利やということで
それで話が終わってるんですよ
だからこの私たちはこの過去の人々の知識を背負っているんだから
新しいものを考えることもできなくなっていて
そこでなかなか大変なんで
理性のある人間っていうのを作るっていうことはなかなか大変で
で ちょっと違ったことを考えちゃうとね
社会がその人を潰しちゃうし
社会に従いなさいと言っちゃうし
だからどう見てももう屁理屈というかね
社会は正しいのか 社会が模範になるのかと
社会って何なのかと それは全然ないんですね
はっきりしない 定義はない
社会に従いなさい みんな言われる通りやりなさいと
という言うだけで じゃあみんな正しくやっているのかと
だからみんなやってるんだからって言ったら
じゃあ私は銀行強盗するだってやっているんだよと
じゃあ私は人殺しするぞと
だって人をやってるんじゃないんですか？と
それも社会でしょうと
いう理屈も成り立つし
だから我々の言葉さえも理性がないんで
ただ言うだけで それで欲があることっていうのは
この過去の人物の真似そのまま持ち運ぶというね
例えば正妻さんにひどくいじめられたとすると
あるいは正妻さんがすごい権力を握ってわがままで
もう大変な性格でしたというと
お嫁さんがそれにはものすごい反対なんですね
なんという女でしょうかと
と反対しながら 次見事にそれの倍自分がやるんです
稀なんですよ 逆の逆の道をとるのは
そういうふうな まあ一応多数派はそういうことでね
少数派の中の少数派は逆の道をとったりする
自分がくたぶたいじめられたんだから
自分はみじんもいじめてあげませんよと
自分が全部権力をあげて引退するんだよと
いうふうに思うのはものすごい稀な人々ですね
自分の両親が離婚したんだから
自分は離婚しないぞと
とにかく頑張る 頑張るんだというふうになるのはなかなか珍しくて
同じことをやっちゃいます
父親がむちゃくちゃ奥さんお母さんをいじめたり
蹴らしたりしたならば
その息子も平気で結婚したら同じことをやるんですけど
父親が父親の性格は最悪でしたと平気で言う
と言いながら 自分のおくさんをいじめたり殴ったりする
そういうことだから まあ人間の生き方っていうのはそういうふうになっているんですね
だからそこっていうのはあまり面白くはないと思いますけどね
我々は能力ないんだから
面白くないということさえも気づかないんですね
というか もう忙しいというかね
もうあれも学ばなくちゃ
これも学ばなくちゃという過去のことをね
経験をね で 一人前になることに必死なんで
一人前になるということは
過去はかなり大量に背負うだけの話なんです
時々テレビコマーシャルでも大人になるって何でしょうか？というコピーもありますけどね
別に答えるわけじゃないんですけど
結局大人になるってどういうことですかね
だから私は答えますけどね
大人になるってことは自分で責任持てるのかと
誰かあの人が口がうるさいんだから仕事はうまくいかないんだよと言っちゃうと大人じゃないんです
自分で責任持てるのかということなんです
大体人間は誰かのせいにしているでしょ
何でもかんでも 私は怒りませんだけど
電車に乗る人々の性格悪いんだから
それ見ただけで腹が立ってしょうがないんだよと
大人じゃないんです で
私に聞いても そういう性格悪い人に何か言うべきか
黙っているべきですかとかね
だから まあそれ答えないんですよ
本人が大人になってないんだからね
言う権利あるんですかね
答えない そういうことだから
人が何か間違いをする場合は
先輩は言うべきなんです
教えてあげなくちゃいけないんです
人間っていうのは学んで成長するんだから
言う人はもっと なおさら知らないんだったら話にならないんですよ
そういう  この理性のあるということが
やっぱり大人ということで
物事は自分で判断する
言うのは簡単ですけど
なかなか大変難しいことなんです
能力ない人はもう結構自分で判断するんですよ
何でも逆さまなんです
すごく頑固で 人の言うことは聞かないで
私はこうやります こう決めたとかね
私は人が何か決めることには全然反対じゃないんですけど
決めたこと あまりも自我で
もう勝手でろくな結果にならない場合は
私も知りません 関係ないんだと何も言いません
これやめた方がいいやっていいんじゃないの？って言ったら相手が怒るんだから
逆にまた攻撃するんだから
それも知りません やりませんし
まああまり私に関係ないんですけどと
聞くなよと 自分が決めたなら
自分勝手に行動すればいいでしょうに
誰かにハンコを押してもらいたいんです
ということは 判断する能力はない
資格はないということなんです
だから大変ですよ まあ自分勝手に決める人々にはものすごくその能力はない
資格もない わがままだけ
自我強いだけ あまり自我がない人は
周りを見て周りを見て真似をする
猿真似するだけで どちらでも同じことで良い結果にはならないんですね
周りを見たって猿真似してもよろしいんですよ
周りが正しければ その保証もないでしょうに
だから生き方の場合は
この物事を大雑把で見ないで
小さなこの 何といいますか
英語ではセルと言いますけど
あの小さなセルごとに見た方がよろしいんですよ
例えば 西洋風なレストランでご飯食べて食べに行ったと
もう日本人だからね こんなのどうでもいい
もうわからない しきたりも何一つもね
ただ珍しい食べ物を食べたかっただけの話でしょうし
そこまでいいんですけど
日本人ばっかりだったら
日本人のやり方でね もう食べた方が食べてもいいんです
別に でもせっかく西洋料理だから西洋しきたりにやりたいと思ったならば知らないでしょうに
その場合は 隣でやっているおばさんやおじさんがやっている真似したってもダメなんです
そのケースだけでね そのセルだけで見ると
西洋料理っていうのは西洋人食べるものですから
そこら辺周り見たら誰か西洋人がいるならば
その人はどんな風にやり方でやっているのか見て
ちょっとそこちょっと真似したっても構いません
あるいは素直にその人のところに行って
実は私もこのフランス料理食べたいと思ってきたんですけど
この食べ方とかしきたりとかさっぱりわからないんだから
ちょっと教えてくれないんでしょうか？と言ったら
その人はすごく喜んで教えてくれますよ
だから自分知ってることを聞いてるんだからね
人間っていうのは 知ってる人は知らない人に教えるっていうことはすごくそのそのままやっちゃうんですよ
嫌だとは言わないんです
どんな人間でも 知らないことを聞いたらすぐ教えてあげたりする
それでも教えてあげない人間いますよ
もうこれはもういるんですけど
そんなにたくさんいるわけじゃないんです
ほとんど何か聞いたらすぐ教えてあげたりはする
そういうことだから そのセルだけで考えると
レストランにもうヨーロッパの人もいて
その人にちょっと教えてくださいませんか？って聞いたら
ちゃんとそのしきたり
食べ方 道具の使い方を教えてくれるかもしれません
それで一つ人間関係も出来上がるし
仲良くもなれるし 自分ももう西洋風にやってみたんだというね
もうなんとなく気分がよろしいしね
だからといって 何でもかんでもその人に聞くわけじゃないんです
ついでに納豆の食べ方も教えてちょうだいと
みんなそれやっちゃうんです
あの人物知りやとすぐ決めちゃうんです
そこが失敗するところなんです
知ってることを教えたんだからといって
全て知ってるもの知り合いじゃないんです
子供っていうのはその失敗をよく母親に対するんですよ
小さい時は何でも母親教えるんだから
なんとなくもう物事なら全部母親知ってるんだよと思っていて
何でもかんでも聞くと
どんどん母親の管轄外になっちゃうんですね
母親にしても もうもう知っていたっても
子供に言えないものもありますからね
だからこの 母親何でも知ってるっていうところで
本当にトラブル起こるんですよ
やがて母を大事にしないし
母のことを信頼しないし
もう攻撃するし いろんなことをするんですね
そこはその間違いで 母であっても父であっても
何でも教えてるわけじゃないんです
人間として 1人前になるまでのことは教えられます
それ以外はできません
子供が医者になりたいというならば
父親はい 分かりました
全部教えてあげる それはできるわけないんですよ
たとえ父親が医者であっても
それは不可能です だからできる範囲は決まってますから
その範囲だけ教えてもらう
そういうことで この物事をセルごとに小さなコマごとに考えて見ることできれば
我々には社会から学ぶことはできるんです
この線でいわゆるコマで考えないんですね
すぐまとめちゃうんですね
全部 だってろくに勉強もしないで中学生の時タレントになってるなるでしょ？女の子たちやらね
あれであのくだらない世界で忙しくて忙しくて
ただぶりっ子で可愛く可愛がっちゃってればいいし
別に演技力はどうでもいいし
それでカウンセラーになるんですね
みんなこういうことでどうしましょうかと
で テレビですごい派手にもうアドバイザーみたいに来て
何も言ってない 何もわからないしね
もしかすると電話かけて質問する人にはもっと人生経験あるんですけど
人々の人生相談を受けている人々っていうのは
自分たちも最悪人生やっているのに
だからそういうところはね
すごい間違いなんですよ
日本でもあるし インドでもそういうことよくありますよ
で 映画俳優とかね タレントさんだったら神様扱いでも何でも知っていると
何でも知っているわけじゃないんです
ただ一つの能力がある
じゃあそこでまねるところあれば
それだけ学んでみて 残りはもうアウト
カット 関係ないんだと
で そういう風に我々は生きているならば
この一応自分の生き方っていうものを見事に組み立てて成り立っていくんです
それが過去を背負ったことにはなりません
当然 過去から学ぶべきことを学んでいるんです
しかし いらんものを学んでいるわけじゃないんです
だから何を学ぶか どこまで学ぶかっていうことは
そのコマごとに このイベントごとに自分がね
見てみると何のこともないんですよ
すごく先進というか 最先端を走って生活することはできるんです
普通はすごい苦労しますね
最先端にいるということには
そんな苦労しなくてもできます
で 自分が生きている環境で
コマごとに何を学ぶかっていうことを見るだけ
それは人間の世界っていうのはそんなところだなと思いますけど
では仏教はどんなことを教えるのかというとね
仏教は本当に生命って何なのかで
生きるっていうことは何なのかと
存在って何なのかと それは見事に分析して教えているんです
ブッダは自分がもう全部発見しましたと言っているんです
だからってブッダを信頼する必要はないんです
ブッダがそれもちゃんと配慮して
誰が調べたってもこの結果になりますよと
私は新しい何か紹介しているんじゃないんだと
常にある事実を発見したんですよ
発明したわけじゃないんです
生きることは苦であるとお釈迦様が発明したんじゃないんです
発見するんです 発見するということは
すでにあることということなんです
人間に知られてない それだけ
誰かさんがアメリカ大陸を発見したでしょう
その人はアメリカ大陸を作ったんですかね
じゃないんです 前からもありました
しかし 一部の人間はそれを知らなかったんです
それで世界に向けて大嘘を言ってるんです
パスコとかも誰でしたっけ？アメリカ大陸を発見したの
はい はい  アメリゴ？ 普通はコロンブスって言われてますけど
コロンブス  あの彼が言うように
実際はあのアメリゴなんとかっていう人ですね
普通は日本ではみんなコロンブスだと思ってるんです
あのアメリカ大陸 でもいろいろ詳しく文献を調べると
アメリカ大陸じゃなくて
その前の何かちっちゃな島を見つけたのがコロンブスで
アメリカ大陸を発見したのはアメリゴ
その人が発見したということになってます
だからそこにある嘘って何でしょうかというと
アメリカ大陸には人々が住んでいたんですけど
大きな嘘でしょうね 私たちが発見したんだよ
何言ってるんですか だからそれでもう歴史に名前を載せてあげて
人類に発見してくれたような感じで
嘘でしょうに もう それでみんな真面目に勉強したりする
何とか何とか国の人が何とか何とかところに行ったというだけの話なんです
それで法律まで作ったりして
最初に発見した人のものであると
その国のものであると
だから住んでいる人の権力まで奪っちゃうんです
アフリカ オーストラリアもそうでしょうに
オーストラリア人には権利は権力ないんです
権利ないんです あんた方はよそ者よと平気で言うんだから
出て行きなさいと 住むところから追い出したりして
まあそういうことは まあそうやって世の中っていうのはへ理屈ばっかしで
まあそういうもう何一つあまりもう真剣に考えたらおかしいだけのことで
で お釈迦様が生きることは何なのか
真理は何なのかではなくて
存在って何なのかっていうことが発見したんですね
それでお釈迦様も私が最初に発見しましたよと
同じこと言ってますけど
嘘言ってないんです アメリカは最初の発見だと
それで人が住んでいたんだからね
初めから その人々もどこかから行ったでしょうに
その人々の生きる権利さえ奪われちゃったりして
そういうインチキ嘘じゃなくて
人類初めて私が発見しましたと
だから生きることに対する真理はお釈迦様最初に発見したんです
お釈迦様前誰も言ったことはないんです
それでお釈迦様の後でお釈迦様が言うのは
同じプロセスやってみれば誰でも同じ真理発見するんだよと
だからお釈迦様が言うんだから
信じます 信じますと言ったことじゃないんです
一人一人あなたも試してみたらどうでしょうか
試してみたら ああ なるほど
同じ真理だと これは偉大なる真理ですから
釈尊の言うことがもうたとえ誰が来たってもね
そうでないと言えませんよ
例え神であろう 梵天であろう
超エリートのバラモン人であろう
超知識人であろう 「私が言うことは間違っている」と言える生命はいませんよと
だからこの最終的な真理をそういうふうに発見して
それ生きることに対する真理だから
地球が丸いと発見することとは随分違います
地球が丸いと発見しても
人間にとっては何のこともないんです
地球は丸かろうと平らであろうが関係なく
我々は生きているだけの話ですね
地球と月の間の距離はもう一センチところまで精巧に測れるんだと
だから我々の日常生活に何の影響もありますかね
で ものすごい膨大なお金使ってね
月に行って 何かこの鏡みたいなもの入れて
それでレーザー光線で計算して
まあ一センチぐらいの精密で距離を測っているんです
えらいこと  [笑い] それも嘘じゃないんですよ
精密じゃないかもしれませんだけど
嘘ってことでもないんだ
だから地球が丸いとかね
月はあれやこれやとかね
星はあれやこれやとかね
まあスーパーノヴァ発見しまったとか
まあそんなのはもう発見ですけど
面白いことは役に立ちません
ただ 飢えている 飢え 飢え
飢え死にになっている子供たちにあげるご飯がなくなるだけ
全部お金そういうものに使っているんだからね
ちょっと肺炎になった子供に注射一つ買うお金がなくて子供たちが死んでいるんです
地球上で  百円がなくて
ペニシリンショット ワンショットに
その代わりに百億円使って測りましたと
距離はと 月と地球の間の距離を測り
精密に測りましたよと
自慢げに言って 世界でニュースで流れ
流したりして すごい賢いですよ
人間っていうのは で 財産分配どのようにすれば
それさえもわかってないんです
お金ってどのように使えばいいかわかってないんです
それでブッダが発見したものはそうじゃないんです
生きることの真理ですから
これは科学者が発見するものじゃないんですね
科学者の管轄ではない
哲学者の管轄になっても構いませんだけど
哲学者もまあ微妙に興味はあるんです
生きることは何なのかと
興味はあるんだけども
アホなことばっかし考えるんですね
あれこれと過去のデータ拾ったりして
アリストテレスなんて何言ったんですか？ソクラテスは何言ったんでしょうか？とかね
あれこれと考えて考えて
で 科学的に発見するものもいろいろ考えて
何か考えるだけであって
一つも発見しないんです
考えたら意見が出るだけでしょ
発見になりません 意見なら誰も持ってますからね
で カンタは生きることはこうやと言ったっても
いいえ それは楽でしょうという意見もあるでしょうに
カンタは随分最近の人だから
もうちょっと勉強すれば真面目
まともなことを言えるはずですけど
そんなにまとめなこと言ってないんです
生きることは苦であるならば
やっぱり微生物にしたっても
ミミズにしたっても ゴキブリにしたっても
鳥たちにしたっても 生きることは苦でなければ真理じゃないんです
それから人間には経験もできないかもしれませんだけど
いろいろもう神々がいるわ
もう目に見えない存在もいっぱいあるわ
で 地球上ね 地球外の生命もいるわ
生きることは苦であるならば
一切の生命に対して生きることは苦でなければなりません
そうなってくると 誰もそんな発見はしていないんです
ブッダ以外は ブッダはそれ発見するんですね
意見出してるわけじゃないんです
お釈迦様は意見という言葉を言っただけでもかなり攻撃するんです
誰かが何か遠いところでの隠れ家
あれはブッダの意見でしょう？と言ったら
すぐそちらに行くんです
あんたそんなこと言ったでしょうと
言うなよと これ意見じゃないんだよと
はっきり言うんです だから
これ発見であることは
そのまま発見で通して学んでもらわなきゃ困ると
ブッダの意見ではありません
だから師匠体っていうのは
お釈迦様がプラーナアンチャサという言葉を使っていて
で アンチャサというのは道
プラーナというのは古い道
古い道というタイトルの経典があるんです
プラーナ 道か町か 古い道ですね
そういうことで 発見ということで町がありましたと
私は発見しましたと で
その町に行く道順も道しるべも全部つけておきましたと
じゃあ皆さんは行ってみたら
その例えを使ったのは
真理はブッダが現れようがなかろうが関係なく
真理は常にあることですね
ただ発見してなかっただけ
それで地球は丸いと発見したっても何の役にも立ちませんだけど
生きることにそって真理を発見すると
それが厳密に役に立つんです
唯一役に立つんです だから人間なら間違いはしたくないし
失敗はしたくないし 幸福にはなりたいしとかね
何か目的があってほしいしね
で そうでないとなかなか生き方ははっきり定めてくれませんし
いろいろなことがあります
それは正しく 間違いなく生きることができるようになるんです
悩むことなく 心配することなく
苦しむことなく 生きることもできるし
なかなか生きることは苦ですから
生きただけでは大したことはないんだと
この苦しみをなくさなくちゃいけないんだと
生きることが苦だから生きることを脱出することが幸福になりますよと
で そんなのはあるのかという疑問が出てくるでしょう
そんなことはありますと
あるんだから言ってるんだよと
ということで 解脱に挑戦しなさいと言うんですね
それでブッダの教えを知っている人が
納得した人が 世の中の教えは何の役にも立たないとよくわかるんです
誰も自分に対し親切に何か大事なことを教えてくれてないんだと
[背景の音楽]お釈迦様は本当に心配して幸福になる道を教えているんだとよくわかるんです
そこはわからなくても
どうでもそこよりもやっぱりこの真理そのものを理解していくと楽しくなるんです
この楽しみというのはいろいろ楽しみ
世の中にありますけど
この知る楽しみはものすごいかっこいいんです
すごいクールなんです
知る楽しみ 食べる楽しみとかね
遊ぶ楽しみとかはすぐ疲れるんですね
飽きちゃうんです 長持ちはしないんです
毎日することはできないんです
毎日ごちそう食べちゃうと面白くはないんです
そういうところに行っちゃうとすごくかわいそうなんです
だからといって 毎日ごちそうを食べる人は
やっぱり食べ物をおいしく感じるために
2 日間すごいまずいものを食べてやるぞとかね
いうこともしないでしょうに
それを 1 日食べないでいようと
そうすると明日ごちそうをおいしく感じますよということもしませんしね
したっても意味がないしね
1 日食べないでいて なんか豪華に食べましたと
それまた 1 日食べないでいなくちゃいけない
で 普通の人いい加減にしなさい
なんとなく ということになるし
馬鹿にられるんですよ
だから毎日ごはん食べると
毎日ごはん食べに行って面白くないんですよ
またぐちゃぐちゃ調べるんです
まあ調べて調べて もうどこかに行くんですけど
それも同じことなんです
すごく誤解なんですよ
誰かすごく珍しく料理できるっていうことはありえないんです
そこで特別な種類の鶏とかね
特別な餌をあげて育てて
これはもうもう 10羽しか作ってないんだからね
10色分子がないんだぞとかね
それで 10年前から契約で作ったって同じ時間なんですけど
何のこともないんです
それにも気づかないんですよ
気づかないんだけど なんか面白くないっていうことにはなるんです
とにかく だから この楽しみっていうのはいろいろあるんです
音楽聴く楽しみ 映画を見る楽しみとかね
ご飯食べる楽しみとかね
花を見る楽しみとか 楽しみはいろいろあるんですけど
かなり矛盾 だらけで 花を見る楽しみあるんですけど
無茶寒かったんでしょうに
それで家で暖かくしていればよかったのに
もう外で寒くて震えながら
何かのあれ なんかあの炭入れて温めるようなもの
ここら辺見ましたからね
それ入れて その中に入って寒くて見ていて
で なんとか何とかガスコンロを持って行って
なんとか食べ物作ったり
これ食って結局どうたことないしね
まあちゃんとした料理
家で食って食べる方が食べ物として美味しいし
そういうものを組み合わせて楽しいっていうことにするんですね
かなり無理があるんですよ
でも ただ花を見てだけでもうまくいかないんですよ
なんとかしたいなという気分にもなるんです
花も咲いてるし 提灯もつけちゃったりすると
あの あえて花がなおさら美しく見えるんですね
そうなってくると ちょっと見るだけではちょっと気が済まないんですね
なんとかしたくなっちゃう
それなんとかすると さらに苦しくなっていっちゃう
後片付けがあるし 準備しなくちゃいけないし
で どうにもならなくなっちゃうんですね
だから そういうなんか楽しみはあるんだけど
すごい矛盾というかね
もう割に合わないような設定になっているんです
それ中で一番高貴な楽しみは知る楽しみなんです
だから物を発見する人やらね
いろんなことを調べて調べてやって
人々はもうものすごい喜んで飲ます食わすも気にもしない
もう頑張ってるんです
発掘する研究家たちがもうどんな険しいところにでも行って
もうどんな無理の中でももうやるんです
テントを張って もう大変苦しいんだけど
全然気にもしない 無茶楽しいんですよ
それが知る楽しみなんです
その中で まあ一応知る楽しみには
あの 矛盾がついてないんです
何か発見したら その人はもう年取って
もう何もできない状態になっても悔しくないんです
いろんなことを自分が調べて発見しましたと
今体力が高くてもうそんな発見できないんだけど
それでも知識の世界では先端にはいる
それから次の世代の人々を研究したり調べたりすると
そういうのをチェックしながら
その論文でも読んだりして
若者が新しいものを発見
すごいことを発見してるな
本人が先にそれを知っちゃうんですね
だから知る楽しみがあると
それは結構矛盾がなく
すすく 続いてしまいますよ
そういうわけで 仏教は
まあ人間をそんなに楽しく
楽しく生きていければね
これ食べるとかね ふざけるとか遊ぶとか何あれはと
あれは品がないんだよと
ブッダ使う言葉は畜生的という
動物的という あれ 動物的楽しみ
動物次元に適した楽しみだと
知る楽しみの方が人間に適した高度な楽しみですよ
いうことにしているんです
知る楽しみには あの やっぱり矛盾もなく
あの ちょこちょこと肉体的な苦痛があったっても
まあそれは大したことはない
なぜならば普段も苦しいんだからね
花を見て楽しめと言ったっても
肉体的苦痛があるんだから
得るもの何もないんです
結局は でも知る楽しみの場合
肉体苦痛はあっても得るものは大量にあるんです
だから割に合わないわけじゃないんです
はい その中で じゃあ我々には発見する楽しみといえば
またちょっと問題があります
これがみんなにできないんですよ
今更皆様もエジプト学者になってやろうと思ったって無理でしょうね
じゃあ宇宙のことを発見してやろうと思ったって無理です
それはもう最初からその世界で踏ん張らないと
たとえそういう世界の人々でも
もう何千人いるんだからね
宇宙船に乗ってやりたいと思ったら何人でしょうかね
たくさんいるんですよ
宇宙飛行士訓練する人々は
いるんだけど 一人二人しか選べないんですよ
その場合も能力 点数高い人っていうことじゃないんですよ
いろんな裏の手が働くんです
だから そういう力ある人は宇宙船に乗ったりする
日本人一人選びますからと言って
それはそれぐらいお金払ってるんだからなんです
大量にお金払ってるんだから
じゃあ一人ぐらいまあいいやということでチケットを取るんですけど
その人は選ばなくちゃあかんからね
また そういうことだから
この知る楽しみ 発見する楽しみはありがたいんだけど
なかなか人間にはその楽しみは得られないっていうことになっているんです
届かないんですね だからみんなに最低やることっていうのは
本を読むぐらいですよ
歴史の本を読んだりとかね
いろいろバイオグラフィというね
自伝とかね そういうものを読んでみたりとかね
ノンフィクションの読んでみたりとかするぐらいですね
知る楽しみっていうのは残っているのは
だからノンフィクションとかなんだかとか
読んでは読んで楽しめますけど
みんな漫画ばっかしでしょうに
そこで漫画に目が頭が脳細胞が慣れているんだから
あれは読めないんです
漫画ならさっさっさっさと読めますけど
だからすごい知識世界も漫画本にして出さなくちゃいけない羽目になっているんです
漫画について私は何も語れません
私は漫画は読まないんだから
読まない理由はわからないんです
まるっきりわからない
なんだこりゃと 私にしてみれば
漫画本を読むのはすごい苦痛なんです
文章でページで早く 一ページのためにこんな本全部ページめくるんでしょうかと
慣れてる人はサッサッと読んでなんかわかったようなわからなかったような気がという状態にはなりますけど
だから漫画に慣れてしまっちゃうと
あの知る世界 またね あるのにちょっとアクセスできなくなったりする
そういうことでちょっと問題がありますね
なかなか手に届かないというかね
我々にあるのはそれほどレベルの高い知る世界じゃないんです
本を読むぐらいで それからもう一つ問題ありまして
ある科学者が何か発見したんだからといって
不安ですよ それよりも自分がやっと一生苦労して研究して
ものすごいお金がかかって何か発見しても
自分のところでアシスタントやってる若者の方が
もしかするともっと能力あるかもしれませんし
その人は教授と一緒にずっといたんだから
教授の研究の世界っていうのはむちゃくちゃ知っていて
時々論文書くところまでもうアシスタント書いたりするんです
そこまで能力あったりして
次にその人がすごいことを発見するかもしれません
そうすると 前の発見はもう発見でなくなっちゃうんです
歴史に行っちゃうんですね
だから すごい苦労して発見して知る喜びあっても
ほんのちょっとのことで他の人別のこと発見しちゃうと
あれが価値がなくなってしまうという
まあ悲しい状態なんですよ
だからかなり緊張に富んだ世界なんですね
あるいは自分が気付かなかった何かポイントがあったりすると
それを他の誰かがそこを見せちゃうと
もうアウトになるんです
だから 世間的なことを発見する
その喜びっていうのは
またよくよく見るとまだ我に合わないんです
あの極力緊張世界でいて得る発見だから
そんなに我に合わなくなっちゃいます
レベル立場が高いんですよ
桜の花を見て楽しむ人よりは
発見の楽しむ人の方がすごいレベル高いことは高いんですけど
どちらにも結局我には合わないんです
はい そういうことで じゃあどうすればよろしいかと
お釈迦様が発見した真理は誰にでも知ることはできるんです
手に届かないということはないんです
生きることの発見だから
自分の生きているんだから
私はどう生きればいいかという世界だからね
万人に共通にできるんです
その知る楽しみ 一番最高なんです
なぜならば それ知る人が正しく生きているんです
苦労はなくなるんです
悩みはなくなるんです
緊張は消えちゃうんです
払うものは何もないんです
やっと苦労して研究して発見したっていうことはないんです
ずいぶん楽々に 生きることを発見することはできるんです
何も自分で払うことは何もないんです
その上 万人に発見できる
だからブッダの教えがすごいんですよ
すべての人類に すべての生命に喜びを感じられる
この知る喜び感じられる真理を語られた
これまた有意義で役に立つもの
なぜみんなにわかるのかというと
生きることについてですからね
生きることについて語って
私にはわかりませんよと
と言いたいんですよね
だからブッダに貶されるんですよ
わかります 理性のある人にわかりますから
形だけ人間で中身は猿だったらさようならと
いう風にすごく すごく侮辱しているんです
それも意味がある侮辱なんです
で それでみんな仏教やるとかなり損するんだよと思ってますでしょ
まあ理性のひとかけらもないということはね
明確なんですね その決まりパターン変えてはいけないみたいですね
テレビとかそういう場合でもよく言われたんですけど
テーラワーダ仏教の戒律
厳しい 厳格な宗教であると
そのバカどもたちがそう思っていて
その通りですよと言わなくちゃいけないんですね
それで私はそんなことを初めて聞いたんですけど
どこら辺厳格でしょうかと
あんた言うことよくわかりませんけど
昔は学生の時代でもよくテレビ局ともやりとりやりましたからね
ある日 このクジラについて何か論があって
いろんな人がいろんな意見言ったりして
まあこれは日本でやっていることだからしょうがないでしょうという一人二人見て
これだけは気持ち悪いんだからやめてほしいとかね
それはみんなディレクターもよくわかっていて
私 あなたはどんな意見かと
私は あのね あんた方にはね
食べ物は全然ないというならば
飢えているんだったらどうぞクジラ取って食ってくださいと
あんた言うことわかりませんよ
わかるわけないでしょうに
結局は そんな知識人じゃないんだから
私はちゃんと意見言ってますけど
しかし しっかりした中立的で
あんなアホな若者たちの意見じゃなくて
ちゃんとした意見出してますけど
理解できないと言うんですね
ああそうですか それカットしてくださいと
で そういうどういうことかというとね
私言ったのは やっぱりクジラっていうのは絶滅状態に陥っていると言っても
人間が死にかけているならば食べるしかないでしょうに
人間守るか 絶滅状態の動物守る
人間死んでもいいやというアメリカ人イギリス人の考え方はちょっとおかしいでしょうに
動物はいいということになっちゃうと
人間は憎むという西洋型の思考でしょう
人間のことを憎んで動物を愛するっていうのは
これはもう西洋型の思考でね
私も西洋人じゃないんだから
それはちょっと気に入らない
だからクジラ食う アメリカ食ってアカンかというと
私の答えは人間が飢えて飢え死にになるようなこと
食べ物が何もない状態になったならば
どうぞと だからもうセクションがあるんです
言わないで言わないんですけど
それを本人が理解してほしいんですよ
世界はあれほどカンカンくたくた
言ってるんだからいい加減やめちゃえばどうですかというね
だからあなた方は歴史上こじら食っていたことは
もうそれは否定もしないで
それもよく分かりますし
あのただ船がね 大変高い船で行かなくちゃあかんでしょ
そこ損したくないんですよ
それだけの話です 何人かの仕事がなくなるんだからと困っているだけの話で
まあそれも分かっていて
まあそこまで言われてもやるのかと
恥ずかしくないのかというぐらいの考え方なんですよ
で わからないんだとそれが
ただ私は反対ですと言って
あ なるほど 外国人だからやっぱり反対だ
それでそれしようと思っているんですね
思考の狭さってのは面白いんです
まあとにかくあので わからない
わからないというね まあいうことはよく言ったりはしますね
みんな 思考狭くて それでブッダが教えることはわからないというのは恥ずかしいんですよ
生きることについて語っているんだから
そこで損することはないというポイントなんですけど
で みんな思っているのは
やっぱり酒やめなくてはならんでしょうとかね
戒律は厳格でしょうとかね
それでものすごく勘違いなんです
お釈迦様は幸福になる道を教えているのであって
不幸になることは教えてあげてるだけなんです
不幸になることをやっているのはあなたでしょうにと
だから本人が自分の考えで
なんで不幸になることをやめないんですかね
例えばお金にだらしなくて
何でも買っちゃうと お金がないと借金すればいいやと思う人に
この生き方やめなさいと
あなたって厳しい人ですね
失礼なことよく言うんですねと
言える 平気でそう言うんです
そういう人々は 借金しなきゃこれ買えないでしょうにと
それから借金取り立てが来ると
困った困った困った 何とかしてちょうだいと
お金貸してくれませんかと
こちらにまで迷惑をかける
皆様にもいるでしょう
例えば父親が借金ばっかりして何人かの前説法されたことあるんですよ
もう借金ばっかりして
娘にもう金くれ金くれと
娘さんもやっと生きてるだけで
だからあなた方は親を大事にしなさいと言ってますけど
私はどうすればいいかと
私のことは捨てなさいよ
親を 親の役目果たしてないんだと
だから小さい時はそういったことだけ覚えておいて
よく頑張ってくれたんですけど
大人になったらもう親の役目果たさないで鬼になっているんだから
まあ親失格だから忘れてくださいと
ぐっとぐっと縁を切ってください
それは仏教的な答えなんです
曖昧中途半端はないんです
で しかし この借金したり
だらしない生き方をする人々は
自分の歩み方で不幸になって
周りにまで迷惑をかけたりしている
金くれ金くれとか 結構いるでしょ
男たちはパチンコやったりして仕事もしないし
朝から晩までパチンコやったりして
家にあるものは全部持っていって売ったりして
それで奥さんがお金くれないと奥さん殴ったりする
で それでも奥さんの方がすごい頭がいいんだから
とにかく借金したりしてお金あげたりするんです
自分が借金すると なんでその男を捨てないのかと
分かりませんだけどね
そういうのが頭がいいみたいですね
だからそういうことを言うと
やっぱり仏教は厳しいと
これ厳しいんじゃないでしょうね
当たり前のことを言ってるだけ
当たり前のことを実行すれば幸福になるでしょうに
自分の収入と払う いわゆる何て言います？そこ
出費 出費でしたっけ？支出
そこはちょうどバランスを整えなさいというのは悪い教えですかね
贅沢してはいけないと言ってないんです
論理的に言ってるんです
収入と支出をちゃんと整えなさいと
それだけの話 だから収入は 10万ならそこをバランスをとる
100万ならそこもまたバランスを整えるし
1000万ならバランスをとる
お釈迦はそれを言ってるんだって
贅沢するなかれとかね
ごちそう食うなかれとか
一言も言ってないんです
外国旅行なんかするなかれとかね
借金までするなよというだけの話
だからこの厳格的な戒律というのはおかしい話ですよ
これブッダを侮辱している
そんなほど現代的に語っている人はいませんし
そこで嘘をつかないで
これは厳しいよと じゃあ嘘を言ってみなさいと
嘘をつきとは何を得られるんでしょうかと
目の前で世の中嘘をついたりして毀損しているのに
もう戦争まで引き起こすし
国と国とすごいトラブル起こるし
会社がクビになるし 大変なことを世の中で起きてるのに
時々偉い人々はね いろいろ嘘をついたりして
バレたところで自殺までするでしょう
なのに仏教は厳しいな
嘘をつくなかねというんだから
やっぱり理性がないでしょう
そういう人には だからそこら辺
ブッダの教えについて
もし喜び感じ始めたら
もう言うことない最高の幸せになるんです
ああ これやと これは本当のことでしょうと
世間ということは全く無茶苦茶でしょうにと
酒をコントロールしなさいと戒めなさいと言っているのは
より体に悪いんだからでしょうにと
体に悪いことっていうのは
使わないのは常識でしょうに
こんなちょっと農薬入っただけで大騒ぎするその人間が
それも全てじゃないでしょう
袋一つ二つだけでしょう
他の品を調べても調べて何もないんですが
体に悪いって麻薬やら酒やらそこはもうパクパクと食べたり
ガブガブ飲んだりして
どこまで理性人やと言いたいんですかね
だから体に悪いものは食べないっていうのは理性でしょうし
だからもう脳細胞を壊す壊れるものだから
麻薬酒をやめなさいというのは理性でしょうに
で そういうわけで ブッダに説かれるものっていうのは
厳密に論理的で理性的で
そこに喜びを感じ始めちゃうと知る喜びなんです
同時に人生も幸福になるんです
それでまたどんな人にもできるんです
それが科学者発見する喜びよりははるかにレベルが高いんです
科学者も発見はするんだけど
人間としては 誰しないんでしょうに
普通の人間でしょうに
大学教授たちもいろいろもう女をいじめるためにいろんなカラクリやってるでしょうにと
だから人間としては普通なんですよ
知識人としては立派かもしれませんだけど
大学教授かもしれませんだけど
若い女の子たちにみんなに手を出すと
そういうところは人間としてはごく一般的ということでしょうに
だから科学的な世界で知る喜びがあるんですけど
人間としては完成してないんですね
ブッダの道ではそうじゃなくて
人間としてしっかりするんだから
何も文句はないんです
人間としてでも良い人はどこにでも安心して居られます
船の上でも飛行機の上でも
どこでも大丈夫です 安心なんです
それで死後も幸福になるんです
年取ってもすごい気持ちいいんです
病気になっても 人間としてできている人は全然心配もしない
あなたはもう長は長持ちはしませんよと
せいぜい 1ヶ月間ですよと言われても
ああそうですか よくわかりましたと終わるんですよ
だって悩むこと何もないんだから
しっかり生きていたんだから
だから最後の一日も しっかり生きてみるんだぞと
で その人の死後も幸福になるんです
で そのそう幸福になる理由がありまして
ブッダの教えを知ると心が綺麗になるんです
生きることはもう極限に何事なく苦であるという話がありますね
それがどういうわけ？どういうわけ？どういうわけ？と調べるんです
なんでこうと言うんでしょうかね
でも時々ちょっと楽しみもあるでしょうとかね
私はカバンは好きでしょうしとかね
もう友達とでも仕事を辞めてた
喋るの好きでしょうとかね
結構楽しいとかね 自分にはいろいろ楽しみもあるでしょう
なのになんで苦というんでしょうかとかね
それで調べていくと 真理だから
やっぱりそうだったのかとと発見があるんです
違うものを発見 ブッダが間違ったということはありえないんです
やっぱり生きることには楽しみもあって
苦しみもあるんだよと
五分五分だよと ブッダが偏見で苦だけやと言って
なんであれはということには絶対ならないんです
ブッダお釈迦様おっしゃったのは
人生は波あり谷ありということじゃないんです
もっと深い真理なんです
誰にも発見できなかった真理なんです
人生 波あり谷ありということを誰でも知ってます
酔っ払いも哀愁の人も知ってます
だからそれが真理じゃないんです
偉大なる人が特に努力して発見する真理には違います
そういうことだから 調べてみれば
ああ やっぱりそうだったのかということになるんですよ
それで人生は本当に苦であると
我々は一時的なものに引っかかっているだけのことだとわかると
どんどん心が落ち着いて
欲がなくなっちゃって
我がなくなっちゃって
謙虚になって 怒り憎しみが消えちゃって
心はおのずと綺麗になるんです
そういう人はものすごい幸福に生きていられますということ
だから  2行目  3行目  4行目で我々に言っていることは
君たちもこの教えを学んで調べてくださいということなんです
この教えを学んで調べると
君たちには学ぶ喜びが生まれていくと
それから発見する喜びが生まれていく
それでおのずから心が綺麗になります
それで問題解決すると
いう芸なんです 実践する人々の場合はね
やっぱりヴィパッサナー瞑想をすることがすごく楽しいんだとかね
何がもうカットしたっても
これだけはカットしませんよとかね
いうふうなことになってくると
最高の幸福なんですよ
今みたいにね まあその気になったら瞑想もしてみるぞというね
今日は忙しいんだ 会社に行かなくちゃと
そういう風にも 一番最後に暇があったらという風になってくることは
逆になるともう本当に幸福な人間なんです
何をカットしても 毎日の瞑想の時間だけは絶対カットしませんよと
それがないと生きていられませんよと
毎日のヴィパッサナー慈悲の瞑想する時間だけは何があってもそれだけはやるぞと
地震が起きて建物が壊れかけていると逃げますけど
逃げ回ります その時でも地震の瞑想だけ今日は30分やるつもりだったから
とにかくそれはもう逃げながらそれやるという
そういうところになってくると最高な幸福者なんですよ
そういう自然災害からも
その人は守られます これはあくまでもそれこそ仮定の話ですけど
例えば大きい建物で自分の部屋を一つ借りて住んでいるとしましょう
すごい大地震が起きて
建物はあちこちひび割れが入ってガタガタガタ壊れていくと
自分がもう毎日やっている瞑想をやっているんですけどね
あと10分あります 10
分終わってから逃げるぞと思って瞑想するならば
その人のところだけ何事もなく残るんです
ほか全部壊れても  そういうことなんですよ
別に証拠はないんですけど
ただ 今作った話ですからね
で 私はもう一応それぐらい自信はあります
ブッダの道への人にとっては不幸になるはずはないという
それはブッダへの信仰の問題じゃないんです
それが法則の問題なんです
生命の問題なんです だから生命の心の働きが慈しみになると
生きる権利を獲得しているんですよ
生きるために作った建物なんですね
だから建物にも義務があるんですよ
守ってあげなくちゃという
建物は人間が作ったんですね
だから守る人に価値があるんですよ
そうなると建物も守ってくれるんです
あまり不思議なことじゃないんです
ただの法則なんです 例えば
よく仕事をして頑張って疲れたらご飯はおいしいでしょ
それで問題起きたりもしないでしょ
おいしく食べられるし
ちゃんと消化もするし
体重増えたり脂肪溜まったりということもないんです
なぜでしょうか その人はちゃんと頑張ったんです
仕事したんです だから権利獲得しているんです
食べる権利を だから食べ物は邪魔しないんです
食べる権利はないのに食べるんだから
もう大変です 食べる食べ物が
なんでこいつは育ててあげなくちゃいけないんだとかね
嫌な奴やと ということだから
消化はできないわ 消化したっても代謝機能が機能しないわ
もういろいろ大変 そういう
ということで これ仏法僧に対する信仰の問題ではなくて
ただ科学的な法則の問題で
五戒を守る人 慈悲の瞑想する人
あるいは他のお釈迦様に説かれた何でもいいんです
お釈迦様に言われたものは守る人守られているんです
だから幸せなんです 不安がないんです
明日どうしようと考えなくても大丈夫です
ということで 話を終了いたします